this is kind of a mixer I'm gonna visit
the Jim and Sam mixer sure is where Jim
and I we were talking to each other and
we said wouldn't it be great we have
this network of people yeah friends
friends we've made it yeah who made it
successful people wouldn't it be great
to get them all in the room together
yeah and to just kind of that way we
could expand the network and they could
all kind of touch each other let's bring
one or two in a time where's our first
two yeah yeah yes Travis is okay well no
I see here I see one you know what that
we don't no matter how much you fog up
those windows there is no mistaking
ladies and gentlemen you'll be right
here some tail just walked in the room
my god okay hi Sandy okay you say hello
jizz and Sandy to the mic you're talking
to the edge is probably because my
girlfriend has a very peaches head which
is a big show in Germany by the way
sandy you know apparently now you have a
writer we have your beverage sandy
dimension how great does Mary Jean look
to try to both ladies look amazing oh
sandy looks beautiful and so does
marriage I'm sorry that I pointed out
about Mary but ya know I met both -
hello I showed of ya by the way happy
birthday to Mary Jeanne it was her
birthday that's right of course that's
why you're here happy birthday we all
remember my guitar and sang happy
birthday to her but you should have
brought a cake it would have been better
[Laughter]
just put a vibrator up my ass I know I
am right but do it anyway sure gonna go
away do anything with my life I did have
a doctor wanted it cut it off once Oh No
thank God Leatherface for the change
yeah why do you listen hit her with a
melon thief he was just crazy guy and he
what he liked me cuz I was 22 and look
you've had this for 30 years
somebody wanted a good 12 I had a roid
so this hemorrhoid has been around for
no I have in two years huh it's like
when you you know it's it's a long story
give me mental problems and that it
affects your [ __ ] I see really a
mental trauma I just had a hemorrhoid
you know instead of going to certain
plate goes your [ __ ] like stress like
they say the way back pain is usually
caused by stress a lot of times maybe
hemorrhoids as well right but you know
what it also could be caused by too much
pushing yes you know you know when when
you're when you're on the toilet like
12-year old sandy with the legs out
straight solid duty [ __ ] you up and
everyone is [ __ ] you up and you still
you know you just want to just be you
more and you just you know push it out
so wait when you were 12 you had all
this tension and yes dress is that what
it was yeah you're not eating fiber no
good filter fish and they didn't have
the Jamie Lee Curtis yogurt back sir no
I don't think yogurt is good fiber you
ever try Activia no I don't I don't like
that [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] yogurt though Jamie Lee Curtis
Peralta yeah Jamie Lee Curtis has great
Baumer legendary dumps yeah yeah Wow
yeah Green's
I see now you're [ __ ] okay now of
course dumb questions you know but it's
too late for the hemorrhoid hemorrhage
there yeah I didn't have a cutoff my
mother took me to Jersey
the doctor said take hot seat baths and
a little surprise the mother [ __ ]
support suppository so you don't do
ain't know now because that thing I
never did anal there's no heart no I've
never done anal because I had a
hemorrhoid you would hurt right yes
I don't even like it ain't no in China I
don't like sexual intercourse if you're
in hard drugs so you like to do like
hard drugs like heroin okay to marry I
was with the angel dust was who are you
smoking it or um by the way for this you
don't know cuz she and Akane just came
in here like just just a shot out of a
cannon pain is uh she's a legendary New
York City
burlesque show no girl in the [ __ ]
hands the naked cowgirl she's a woman of
a certain age yes she keeps her sex
appeal right yeah you know and you can
see a photo of her if you've never seen
her at Jim and Sam show on Twitter and
then you know in are in in the red
corner we have the red glitter we have
give me the green maryjean course our
great friend hairdresser slash porno
actress slash on the street reporter for
Jimmy oh yeah I think I'm still in the
mix you are sure absolutely
now sandy are you surprised that you
said some things when you walked in the
studio a little on the vulgar side and
Mary seemed a little taken aback by it
big time right and were you surprised
using Mary jeans being slightly prudish
no she's just being herself streets of
Times Square right so I am there all the
time in the summer right and I so it's
[ __ ] everybody mother [ __ ]
everything is feeling starting [ __ ] let
me just that [ __ ] everybody I feel like
she's saying [ __ ] me she is it came
out of love because I think I've been a
little bit more sexually active than
normal so I understand have I really
have you know a lot of sucking a lot of
toe sucking you've been doing toe sock
here people havin sucking Joe's oh do
you like sucking toes I just got you 16
with hoes I'm not a fan of 69 with toes
though like so you you're sucking each
other's toes of the same thing kind of
happened from head to toe I like the
song did you like sucking his toes her
it was ahem and his feet were really
clean but it was okay dig is like a
little bit more my style
[Laughter]
wait so you don't like sucking balls
I never sucked a ball what do you do if
they're there I just you know I never
thought about balls I always think about
dick you know that's why I go will you
hold the ball if you're performing oral
sex on to be honest man I never really
thought about balls I see by the way
what a great bumper sticker I never
really thought about balls Mary you
can't as somebody you've thought about
Paul is quite a bit there there right so
you you give them thought are you
surprised to hear Sandi say she's never
even thought about them I mean I see I
just I I don't you know that when you're
sucking a dick you don't look at the
balls oh my god I see that's it it's me
but maybe you see the balls
I see the balls I see fingers I see arms
you know that's sex is about the mind I
like a man's eyes and it's more about
the mind that you [ __ ] the man it's not
and his job is not true are you single
Sandi you sound like you're [ __ ]
single because it's a better
relationship the man is gonna want Sam
yeah I know just loves everything that's
why you're like in love with someone
you're exactly
you better start sucking toes you know
you know what I think about years ago
when I worked in it in a cage as a go-go
dancer
and he said he said a take off your shoe
and he left to your toes it was really
to toes and he's giving money man
[ __ ] here's the toes you know and it's
like de jiggle the toes he was really
into toes I have never uh ever but when
he gave you the money you didn't suck
the toes
no he just wanted to see them no her
toes you saw your feet stinky feet I
never smelled my own feet
how do you now hello mmm your boobs are
in the way yeah
hey waves are other people are here and
yeah oh they're gonna bring them in oh
yeah yeah now Mary when you see sandy
cane do you think to yourself there is
life late it late what I can go very
long in life as an adult performer clear
I'm making more money than ever yeah on
the street used to do porn sandy never
good for you
no but I've worked with a lot of porn
stars I was like the opening act for
many porn stars like care-a-lot and
Samantha's whatever I feel like we have
you know these beautiful women in studio
yeah you know oh my god but
unfortunately I'm married yeah neither
one of them have penises so it's tough
for us absolutely but I feel like when
you're scissoring we me that's right we
need to bring in somebody who has not
been having a lot of luck with women and
I think that maybe you ladies can answer
some of his questions yeah and who knows
maybe even maybe even one of you ends up
really hitting it off with why are you
looking at me Sam Robert well I I think
that he's gonna really like you I met
him outside I was like such a fan I
wrote something on Instagram and stuff
which is weird cuz he added me on
Twitter and then he deleted me right
away and I was like hey that's not cool
I'll go a little weird nah that's him
about it yeah I know and you know you do
love him of course you're gonna you're
gonna like this because he actually
divorced his first wife for him because
her breasts weren't big I heard yeah
yeah
I'm the number one fan of the Jimmy
Norton and Sam Roberts
I appreciate you heard the second sample
he was talking about it so enthroned or
phony so ladies and gentlemen let's
please welcome back to this show Chris
Morgan who's now known as the angry
bagel guy yeah the artist the artist
formerly known as bagel boss yeah
now angry Baker come right up to the
table yes it's angry bagel guy formerly
known as bagel boss how you doing and
welcome a Romeo and he brought his
friend Romeo with him you can like that
buddy from the videos which was the
second one all right we all hate Royce
now uh Chris you ran into Syd first of
all welcome back thank you thank you for
having me yeah we've been following your
success as of late yes your exploits um
you got into some legal problems you
can't be the bagel boss anymore is that
right
yes possibly yeah but it's no big deal
we have a bunch of alternate names
that's gonna work it's it's fixed right
away angry bagel guy is fly actually
almost like that better yeah it kind of
sums it up
everyone says that actually right right
right it makes sense to me so so how's
life how's life you view your now we saw
you first in the afterglow of all your
viral success it's been several weeks
now you're getting ready for a big fight
with Lenny Dykstra right how's life it's
going good man it's good see I'm not
sure because I watched your YouTube
videos and you dressed up like the Joker
and you started screaming about how
women were we're treating you poorly and
also that you were not a rapist what
that is yeah you made that very clear
oh absolutely yeah you made a video
letting the world know he's not a rapist
yeah what are they do another
compliation video but a comical twist
but I was doing that stuff with face
paint with my friends when I was younger
too but I figured let me just kind of
wrap this up and give my last thoughts
on just those specifically that have
wronged me not everybody right every
woman in general obviously but yeah and
I heard no as far as the views go which
none
so your your one wife we talked about
that you were not pleased with her
breasts I want to get into that was that
was my that was my fault well didn't
divorce because he are you looking at my
no I'm looking at your eyes whatever I
got weed pasties on [ __ ]
hey but you know little pattern pain
make you look like what you ain't is
that you are married a good plastic
surgery and I wish I could get one are
you saying marry add more dicks and then
why don't what happened to you sucking
toes you forgot the balls like a man's
balls but not just suck on him to do
what I do like a man with [ __ ] balls
like Jim Sam yes I hate your long just
forge [ __ ] through man you got your
[ __ ] balls
and women with balls like her and me I
date them no wait wait wait balls I want
to say hello to uh Krista's friend who
we've seen in video Romeo
yes how you doing honored to be here
today
yes yes and I think thank you thank you
my my friend my best friend and stop
being nervous the Train loosen up we
could smell it way lewd he does a lot of
times I think he likes Stella Stella I
think it drinks a little bit
your name bagel what's that how did you
get your name bagel sandy wants to know
apparently she doesn't have the Internet
oh so you never saw the initial you have
the Internet I don't know bagel man I'm
looking at you means am i don't know why
she's watching our videos you're not too
impressed with him no I'm not saying
that okay I see you dick okay well
should have many bigger dicks sometimes
man if Schuette dicks sometimes
sometimes romeo tell us the truth is the
angry bagel guy is he packing does he
have a big one no you see the one
dancing in the deli yes it sounds like a
song that's the TV I was telling you by
the way that's the screen we saw it on
that day
Travis you might need to help that Troy
find find Romeo's biggest breakout hit
and the reason really why we asked Chris
to have him come in but Chris we also
wanted you to meet some women because
you know it seems like you've been
having a lot of trouble we watched your
video where before you went fishing you
made a video and you sent it out to
everybody and said I'm about to go
fishing but if anybody in the Suffolk
County County area wants to [ __ ]
smoke weed to hit you up in this you get
hit up in the DMS that evening uh I
probably did I I don't remember what the
exact stuff was I believe I did but not
actually one throw hey have you had a
lot you trained a little bit you always
created training he's always fighting
with a liar Quinta how is that are you
taking mixed martial arts not martial
arts just his style strictly a little
bunch of you know some boxing maybe a
little bit of kicks that's it okay
basic stuff now are you worried because
last time you were in you were talking
about a possible fight with Antoine
Dodson from YouTube obviously that
turned into the Lenny Dykstra fight
right but there was a heavy implication
that you didn't
really have to worry cuz that fight was
gonna be fixed this one wouldn't be is
this like gonna be fixed or fight oh
that's right athlete don't even make a
flee yeah he's been perhaps tipping a
few back for the last 35 years okay you
want to marry do you want to see this
video over over it's your best friend
Chris yes he's one of two of my best
friend okay that's nice can you hear
sandy yeah I'll make sure sandy came
here okay testies testies
he's just plastered as usual acting like
an idiot giving the finger hey Romeo
cover your flippin everybody off in the
dancing you love the deli now where they
love you yes the people that were eating
there they couldn't have been thrilled
with you doing like suck it [ __ ] you you
know well then normally over that's
crazy crazy crazy crazy for the guys you
work Romeo you work when you work what
is your special he doesn't work he's he
cannot for a while I say sieve it out
for a while unemployed for a while yes
computer graphics okay yes why did you
laugh so hard when he said not at the
moment I smoke three bullets and a
[ __ ] fan the oil [ __ ] yeah you are
right yeah you're under the influence at
the moment okay good for you it's a
party I'm glad that he told you who is a
party now Romi are you under the
yeah we should have had some liquor yeah
got a bottle in here I have a party you
know that man
who's your friend early Sam I don't know
yes I really would yeah two guys here
both of these guys are very horny in
this so where's the [ __ ] liquor I
asked you guys that that's a good
question Romeo I'm gonna ask you yes cuz
you love the ladies right right your
your instagram name is what is it Travis
could you remind me Romeo the room the
Romeo the romancer okay I'm surprised
that was available I actually named you
did it was the perfect thing for you cuz
you see him with the ladies so much yes
that's amazing so if you had your pick
Romeo who are you going after you going
after Mary Jean are you going after the
more experienced and Sandy Games would
you stand up for Romeo please sandy
would you mind standing up as well for
yes sandy is a no and we'll see that's
cool sexy right hold on we got a mic
sandy and hold on one second we'll just
have them Turner's here what do you got
Bo or something she's asking Romeo right
go Jesus what's going on what are you
doing later let's exchange blood test
whoo that's a good one so Romeo grab
that mic if we have that team yeah grab
that - where are down Romeo
[ __ ] yes and if you want to do a
little material on Romeo go yeah I mean
on stuff no I mean do you have a big
dick
hower like a little quarter pounder on
long tongue
what kind of sex do you have yes sir
Mary why we're nice lady packing yeah
hard core yeah what do you like to do
everything everything what's your
favorite you like to eat out are you a
lesbian do you eat out you like to eat
out sometimes you know and I don't want
to go for a lesbian or anything I hear
they have good tongues oh yeah yeah that
was like that all right
yeah have a nice yes good stuff this is
really sexy everything that comes in the
package okay shake it baby shake II who
you saying you like Chris to marry my
Romeo is over there doing really well
with sandy what do you say you I'm eight
second you said she's my type yeah like
that hole off you know Oh Mary Jean the
black hair right the late Mary Jane this
guy bagel has a short dick you know and
I know dick yes you do I worked in peep
shows I know dick and what about him
what about Chris the bagel guy um he's
short buddies I like him that's Romi
that's Romi I came because he's kind is
it just me or is there a romance Mario
this chemist chemistry very beautiful
person that's amazing you like me yes
you like me because we go together
you're kind I'm kind Andi is bending
over to take a look in the [ __ ] that's
why I like to be honest with this you
don't mind a dear a roid you don't mind
a hemorrhoid no it doesn't see is Romeo
very picky with the ladies I don't think
he is the exact type do you want exact
height I like Mary what about Cindy no
no sandy Cain is the one that's in front
of you with the hat sandy but Mary man
where this guy said or just like ha he's
my exact I like Mara
we assault whoa now I would say that in
Time Square no I'm very honest and you
know you're not my type anyway
why not what makes it not your type well
these internet famous
you know I think you should come inside
a gigolo that's it you think you should
come in a bagel why is he not your type
physically what do you not you have your
kindness okay your tits are too small
for me sweetheart pussy's too big for
you you're probably right you sure do
[ __ ] you do your own makeup here or
did someone do that for you your makeup
down here she's a makeup on the
paintbrush thing that is like Agnes says
naked no not that on your the American
flag on the nipples
those are stickers because I like to I
like to uh legalize weed let me ask you
something Romeo the romancer you look at
that does it make you feel like singing
god Bless America maybe yeah heavy real
bosoms that sandy has they're lovely you
don't mind a nice tag do you shake her
boobs are nice very nice look at them
they're nice shakes them all over Times
Square should be very popular
he's like incredible smack your own ass
sexy pants you can see him right through
[Applause]
thank you he's got he's got to give a
compliment to Mary you know he's gonna
fight lenny dykstra
Christa he's fighting Wow greetings
gonna win sandy um Romeo Lenny Dykstra's
he is a big what what team was here play
with the Metropolitan's gonna win
despite because Lenny is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I met him at the strip club and
he was a total drug addict loser I mean
I didn't see him do anything but he was
such a mess and he was so rude Kris I
was like that might be good in a fight
yeah you want a guy who's ah who's you
know Lenny's a rough guy so I gotta tell
you his weakness because I saw it like
I'm a stripper too so I don't I'm where
people are just in general their penises
come out touching his penis because I
was there and he was doing it right in
front of did he say anything very rude
if you say so you know if you say so
yeah all I can do is take your word
that's right just because did he say
anything very rude that sticks out in
your mind or no nothing really vocal
just actions right did he really horny
did he have a big dick theoretically I
never saw it Oh
at work yeah and if they take it out
take you throw them out
oh I don't know okay we're getting into
that wash it but she thought you here
what do you say she didn't see it but
she thought you here so who does your
penis
touch Lenny Dykstra's penis it let's
face it maybe no Mary Mary we'll take a
Liberty one Lenny Dykstra who the [ __ ]
cares right and Rob ye Romeo's right
there Romeo is there it Chris is there
these are both single guys from the
internet famous are they saying are you
single - I know are you gay yes
[Laughter]
yeah this was gonna happen
Romeo and sandy are in the corner she
said take care o mucho which means I
love you a lot
yeah you know and and Romeo's over here
like look there maybe you know it's
worth holes a hole right Romeo so sexy
she's so penetrating no patriotic
patriotic
Wow
would you want a motorboat Romeo would
you want to do that sandy that [ __ ]
sandy can he do it hold on sandy
microphone freaking [ __ ] [ __ ] c'mere
[ __ ] that [ __ ] honey
I need you to come back to the table
you're not wearing headphones any idea
what's appeal I can't fault her for it
no but you're not listening you have no
clue what's going on it's cuz you don't
have headphones your breasts hurt your
breasts are a big hit meanwhile I have
DNA his DNA on my [ __ ] tits yes
that's nice that's good to hear that's
what we're hoping for nine o'clock in
sports so that's why the meeting room
you little monster yeah Romeo the
romance very smooth I'm surprised it I
even let someone do that
well you're not easy to charm but I know
you like Romeo no I like Jim and Sam and
do you like Romeo I like Jim and Sam
show [ __ ]
good for you we like you the worst is
the best is the breast absolutely
versatile I really like doing that now
meanwhile while this is going on I'm
listening out of one here damn Sam Chris
keeps whispering sweet nothings to Mary
Jean keeps telling her how perfect she
is okay now he's making me nervous
now interesting enough interesting you
know you never know I never ate
someone's cleaner going oh I see
interesting enough and Chris you're a
fan of marijuana you like that yeah sure
so so is Mary Jean Jean likes to partake
in you're gonna think this is funny a
lot of times on the show we go Mary Jean
likes Mary Jane catchy it's funny right
well do you do any acting Chris I mean
you are getting very famous now yeah no
I mean have you thought of acting I well
believe it or not I've done it all my
life like with friends but acting I I'll
get into it sure if the opportunity
arises yeah absolutely I don't feel Mac
yeah
anything I guess you're doing porn
probably yeah you got to would you do a
porn yeah
can you guess with who movie Willem
Dafoe the better than Chris the bagel
guy super famous and and being with a
brilliant actor like him up for the
Academy Award - that [ __ ] movie you
know your back because I remember you
emailed Willem Dafoe email noises again
and I had my new movie out it as as this
doing this film let me let me plug you
see we got sandy properly we got this
from your email will plug everybody of
course Mary Jean X Oh Mary Jean XL on
Twitter and Mary Jean xxx on Instagram
of course the lion beauty salon as well
sandy Kane is at Sandy Kane five four
eight five on Instagram
Sandy's new film Don't Look Back is
apparently on Vimeo but I can't find it
no it's I'm just reading the plug
sandy also says
sandy also says it will be at the South
they will be at the southeast Southwest
Film Festival in Austin awesome but she
probably means South by Southwest yeah
yeah oh yeah what's the name in the
movie don't look back
where is it us on Vimeo well it was but
do we had to take it off because what
when you do like nah yeah because they
don't like when you're it's exploited
like that so you have to take it off and
just give them but there is a password
if you want to see the film and you're
in the movie and you're in the movie Wow
okay I'd really like you see the film
because I do not get my commission make
money - yeah thank you Mary but Jerry's
my agent doesn't matter lawyer
documentary if you just feel people put
movies well drivers let's see if we can
get that password Bay because I'd like
to uh you didn't see you know I know I
didn't know I was in a movie you're
saying no I'm gonna be in south to east
south west yeah yeah yeah yeah what are
we doing it do we sound good yeah
incredible
you make the movie and he cues chair
pulls in it to have you and Anthony made
up no I would love to alright because
he's a good guy he's just a wise guys
well Keith I love the chair situation
well but now I made it like funny
because it says Cheryl when she's a
chair and I fall backwards it's
hysterical
on film and you're okay ever see the
video like did you actually see it he
wasn't pushing the chair
what was he there was a video of teeth
uh hop Keith he was moving the chair
sandy was in at Sandy fell out of her
chair and Sandy held quite a chair and
at one point did threat huh I saw and I
don't ever see them opening that either
so he'll how did I fall backwards you
just fell you should have watched her
back a little oh you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I saw you and Harry I know other people
suffer it too
you know accidents happen now do you
think it happened but it was a mistake
it was definitely on sandy's part sandy
man mistaken what you're saying I don't
know and you decide to still come back
and associate yourself with friends that
are really close with these guys so you
look like you're desperate to so like go
ahead and call me a [ __ ] with that cuz
that's not cool well no Jim Norton said
something to me I always remember it
some sometimes you tell her secrets gem
she might spill it sometimes you do
stupid things and you were right not you
or even people in general people
sometimes people do Anthony and Anthony
didn't do the chair thing so you're just
trying to go everybody that has money
that's not cool
okay you know what I mean yeah I do Who
am I gonna go for it so much more like
when they give you the motorboat you for
zero dollars yeah yeah yeah all right
stop that come at me sandy cuz I've been
nothing but nice to you exactly I love
lo these Latin people would okay that's
coming across this race Romeo is it your
fiance I'm racist I did the middle
finger I'm white I do the middle [ __ ]
finger I'm real I have do two fingers
all right Romeo what do you think she
does two fingers Wow
now Chris so you call you an ethical
makeup mending fences right love - I
love Antony Hewish very good I see now
Chris something else you don't know
about Mary is clearly she's got a bit of
a an anger issue that has been described
not by me but by other people as
somewhat toxic which you can probably
relate to it's definitely not toxic I
say we agree we neither I don't think
it's toxic parsley for me tell me I mean
a girl that looks like that and the
angry of the [ __ ] you like she's
angry with a lot of girls you know let
me tell you what I don't have on my ass
you know I did I know you did you come
on the show looking pretty right yeah
tiny hole my hemorrhoid mite is tight -
oh that's good little speed bump on the
road a speed bump on the Hershey Highway
judge a person by one Roy now
we're imagine exec gonna marry me
because I have a hemorrhoid
Romeo you don't give a [ __ ] listen cuz I
never let him me and go back there oh
you never did never Oh the hemorrhoids
been around for a long time twelve years
old right
alright now Mary you know what it smells
like when a person is able to orgasm out
of their body is that correct
well yes of course you know I love all
smells I know all smells so smells like
a baby donkey Roberts favorite smell no
I've never done yeah I I was never into
it but I heard it's like fabulous you
have you've only heard good things
guaranteed fresh and rotten tomatoes
anal is like you know and I can't see
how people felt that [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
they don't have hemorrhoids it's easier
is it that that bothers yours is the
fact that some can happen you know I
don't know it's not very erotic even
though you know gay people do that you
know don't knock it till you try it
though yeah you might like it doesn't
matter of gay or straight does it it
feels good exactly be a little more woke
right yeah you might like some man could
do Wow you know just certain men know
how to make love you know how to make
love Jim and Sam what I have two
children some on the books yes I'm
protective so you know I'm saying I I
have evidence of sexual intercourse okay
two children okay I've done it at least
twice right Chris that's how it works
brothers have a strong seed that's right
it's drugs
you have two kids now so in this
that's right what about you Jim you're a
single guy man yeah I know I don't make
love well at all not good I have
fledgling erections and I get nervous
and I blink a lot no Chris how much
fornicating have you done since the
angry bagel boss video holy mountain not
too too much believe that a little bit
is that because the women they play mind
games yeah but you know what I realized
too a lot younger like in in lower 20s
and I'm like that's the problem
there's no changing their image I didn't
realize that I realize you know what
that's a pattern and I gotta bump it up
an aged a bit
you talk in Sandy's age or Mary's age
thirty
yeah like around that agent up is
probably preferable okay
up as high as sandy you're right though
you're right if you meet the right exact
one where the chemistry's right you know
they say age ain't nothing but a number
but that was actually written master
Jeffrey Epstein said yeah our Kelly
wrote that for a fifteen-year-old so
maybe he's a pedophile what are you a
pedophile what you didn't guess he's
saying he likes women who are older than
25 I'm attracted to you we have
chemistry that's all yeah they're a kid
it's fine yeah I like younger guys no I
didn't say that no no man he's a man you
know you can meet a young guy and he's a
real man what's the youngest you've ever
dated 12 Tyros have you dated a 12 year
old before sandy be honest well at least
he's 813 when he's born mid speed man
and if I may ask just what is a woman's
definition of a real man like Baldy
what's like what's your idea of sandy
what's your definition yeah I don't want
to hear us Romeo knows I'm a big fan a
Jeffrey Epstein okay what a terrible
person is dead I know you and I only go
pedophile but I feel that
lot of men go for 15 16 year-old girls
that's kid that's not my goal I know
it's illegal but I think a lot of men
are attracted to younger women even
though they don't make a move those are
girls those are women those are children
yeah that's so what do you like about it
sweet 16 in fact the beginning of my
movie is me at my sweet 16
really so it's sandy you remember Jim
earnest sandy keen at his sweet 16 on
the beach looked looking absolutely
gorgeous damn Bradley Beach cheats hair
I mean I looked absolutely going after
he was a pedophile
yeah but he went for did I think a lot
of men do they don't make a movement
what you're saying basically is that
he's no different than a lot of creepy
guys right now she's saying it's not
even creepy well I mean I feel like when
I saw myself at 16 I said I was
absolutely gorgeous
are you happy with yourself now it
sounds like you're still living in the
past then it's it's something that US
women we deal with Mary Mary and I'm not
in I'm talking to you like a real woman
share or Gordo's be alone II know I'm
not being a [ __ ] phony a stupid
[ __ ] now calling me phony and chef
sandy nice try gnarly you and
woman-to-woman let me just tell you what
happened [ __ ] is right cuz I called her
a [ __ ] and she now you're a stupid
[ __ ] no yeah you're I don't see my
finger yeah you're not following the
video of me at 16 I'm so afraid to see
it thank you thank you thank you thank
you I'm so great to see you
but Jim do you think we should hire
Romeo to be like our no wonder your best
friend like rock stars but anyway I
wanted to say that at the beginning of
the movie so I didn't want to see the
film of me at 16 because I was so afraid
that I'm older now I don't want to see
myself I finally looked at it and you
know I like myself better now you're
happier now because she matured yeah
because like you know little pattern
paint make you look like what you ain't
and also i me I'm not my parents I'm not
my Jewish parents I'm not down the
Bradley [ __ ] Beach
I'm not on bagel beach I'm on the Jim
and Sam show on Sirius XM rushing headed
by wonderful Howard Stern I've nothing
it's not a church yeah he's not here
Howard Stern is beautiful person by
nobody hey that's my boy watch yourself
I hate to [ __ ] Howard Stern but anyway
chairman Sam and no I love the I just
got a spit-take out of the baby I always
I listen Sam I don't listen Ali but I
love how it's your in anyway okay good
good I'm glad that we I'm glad that we
had that soliloquy I don't remember
exactly where we started
point wise or why we ended there I think
that that was your justification for
pedophilia
oh yeah because you said Jeffrey Epstein
is your hero we did you know what she
likes she said hero did you see her yes
she did I didn't say hero
okay let's go to the tape cuz you
definitely said I think he's a hero no
that's what you just said I didn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
are there sparks going on right now
between Chris the bagel guy and Mary
Jean I was a big fan since the day I saw
your video here's the issue a normal
later if you want that's up to you would
you want to take Chris's number because
here's the issue that I worry about Mary
you're you're a nice person you're very
polite you treat people well however
chris has often publicly complained
about the way women treat him she's not
like that you know just feed him on
she's not Shady I could tell she's not
Shady like you know how do you know when
you leave because you'll be shooting
yeah but you guys are gonna be on a
double date you should get along because
you marry which would you go I just
asked you hypothetically you haven't
asked her to do this yet or anything
like that right now but would you go on
a double date with Chris and Romeo sandy
with Romeo you with Chris would you go
on that double date I actually have to
head over to line beauty salon you're
more welcomes consul-general I work
Wednesday through Sunday from 10 a.m. to
8 p.m. so you can stop by anytime I
could give you a massage we do facials
so she wants your money along I mean a
date date I was gonna charge him I don't
have to it's my place
how about this Chris why don't you pitch
to Mary what your idea of a date would
look like and see if it's something Mary
might be interested in what harm could
that be well what are your hobbies
I mean besides having fun and sucking
dick you don't golf obviously right
you're gonna take Mary Jane out golfing
you got Mary Jean and you're like let's
go to the golf let's go fishing
you know Chris this is a date you want a
romances do you think Romeo the romancer
would take a girl fishing that was no no
he'll know where she is she's easy she
just let him motorboat for free over
there in the corner how much would you
charge him with those phony tips Oh God
[Music]
real fake [ __ ] tell her what a real date
would be like cuz you're a nice guy
you've got some some fame a lot of [ __ ]
going on yeah how do you romancer well
I'll tell you what if I ever reached my
goal which is I want to get a yacht I
would just basically know Chris is we
got a deal in reality before that if
Mary goes I am free this weekend Chris
what do you have for me to tempt me what
are you doing with maybe a comedy show I
mean just a fun night now ya know young
LaSalle with Jim Norton take her what's
up
the Comedy Cellar with you yeah yeah
I'll be there the fall for together we
won't be Chris
Miguel actually has a question for Chris
if we can go to the phones real quick
Miguel in Los Angeles again hello
everybody yeah yeah but hey Chris how
are you still syllabus no syllabus good
question became a very good Miguel good
memory yeah so why would you take her
before you where would you take her
probably nice dare than a comedy club
maybe a walk on a beach on Long Island
do you like Long Island I like it okay
what are you resigning again in the
Bronx oh I had an aunt I grew up in the
Bronx by Pelham Oh Lamar ah you don't
know char's palmi area from Bronx Tale
sure yeah well my aunt before she died
used to seem in a bakery the bakery what
a coincidence
a local bakery out there in a Bronx oh
yeah yeah absolutely he was a news
notoriously he loved bakeries yeah you
love cakes and things of that nature
yeah mugs is good to score drugs that's
all
[Music]
you live anywhere because you don't live
anywhere I live in Hell's Kitchen [ __ ]
smarter and you're stupid
have to talk to you anymore bye [ __ ]
bye [ __ ]
when I'm saying is I live in Hell's
Kitchen it's very expensive and that's
where I live it doesn't matter where you
live you sound stupid yeah I think I
know I I think it does matter where you
live okay that's actually a pretty honor
point I mean sleep politics don't you
agree right no thanks all right so now
that we know Chris's date is more of a
play it by ear
why are you what if you how about this a
dinner guy Chris don't let me tell you
what to do or anything but what if you
put took her on the Chris the bagel boss
tour you brought it to the bagel boss
store and you're like this is I'm
actually not allowed in there okay you
were Banford they won't let you come in
for you it's okay oh my I'm a nice girl
sure sure
have they heard of I bet they know about
egg whites by now though am i right
the woman that was told me that does she
quit internship I didn't want it let me
ask you this Chris what we're talking
about videos I did have a question about
one of your previous releases on your
channel yeah I saw there was another
altercation on your YouTube channel it
was you you were in a car and there was
a man on a motorcycle selling you it
looked like hassling you and you guys
got into an argument yeah now somehow
even though the video was shot via would
appear to be a GoPro on the motorcycle
man's helmet it ended up on your YouTube
channel yeah how did you guys get that
footage I first I got a CD I don't even
remember this there it is right down
bottom row there Troy angry there it is
the blue car yep I told you last week
just walk around naked with you Chris
you can do whatever you want
I was going to my nights on cleaning
this car was a pawn car member him
because he had nice paint job yeah yeah
yeah yeah which we did that by the way
by him that paint job a cheap one with
the spray cans oh we all did that that's
surprising
so how did you get this video he that
caught me off or he got real close the
video itself the video that's him that's
him I know but it's on your channel I
have no idea okay and people are
speculating here casino fight was a
fixed that it was fake trying to get
some more okay you could tell that was
real yeah it started out with I knew
this girl and we didn't talk anymore and
that she gave this tape she became
friends with somebody else on Facebook
this girl and then she just started hit
me up in the middle of the night and I
went to go there and she kicked that
girl right there I wanted to give her a
kiss she's like you see like you don't
you yeah and I wanted to basically like
I just wanted to give her a kiss on the
cheek and she wouldn't let me I says
well then I'm leaving and I walked
around a play quick hit and then they
called me again and and they where are
you and then they came over and that's
when he started you know mouthing off
and then I says you know get away and
then the video takes over I'm trying to
like get him out of here yeah you're
trying to fuzzy cock-blocking the cloud
chases cloud chaser that's all they're
just trying to Sue's anthony and then
she's still here trying to suck dick
she's a dick sucker oh yes I am oh you
are a lookup brazzers in reality King
right now you're a little smartphone
[ __ ] you can find your scenes there
right I thanks of course of course
they're very good scenes yes indeed they
are they're very good see they are it's
porn oh yes yes it is I did yes I see
her have you seen Mary's movies okay I
don't even I don't even have to see the
movies I mean just looking at her right
I have act something actually you added
me on Twitter and I went to add you and
you're already on follow me
what the [ __ ] who followed you there oh
my dog might have been in action because
all my marriage is control us I don't
like accidents with I don't like that Oh
I know I didn't personally follow each
other later you hit me up sorry I don't
know if Mary wants her watching porno
explain it to them but imagine if you
just met a girl and I'm like hey I see
you and Pryor talking look at his she
sucks - trying I hope so that's he so
don't don't even get your hopes up
I'm not getting or you dick Mary Jean oh
geez I'm sorry do you like boxing of
course I love boxing I heard Chris has a
boxing match yeah my second hitch smoke
they let him picture now Romeo before we
go why don't you describe to sandy
that's fair what a date would be like
with you I mean sandy and you have
really hit it off obviously what would
it be like with you and sandy let's go
see Jim Norton at the Comedy Cellar I
mean it's a little awkward no didn't
like go see I mean Jim does a great show
but I'd love to go to Comi Club I love
comedy clubs you like I know I'm there
every night stop letting my stalkers
know I put you both on a list if you
wanted to come on a date to one of my
shows if I'm doing a show yeah it feels
a little unoriginal though no what about
seeing a movie once upon a time in
Hollywood there you go that's a [ __ ]
movie it is it's fun yeah that's a [ __ ]
movie yeah yeah like caviar is playing
in Brooklyn Friday
sandy what did you say
that's a great question actually a lot
of people are wondering this choice ban
you know sandy what you may not know if
I get to our [ __ ] Club bring
your guitar maybe woman do a little
something okay
Troy is actually he and is in his group
Black Caviar they remix a lot of music
so if you want something and this is
serious that may be able to make you
like have a little bit more of a
contemporary sandy does electronic music
get what Troy after the show because
he's always looking for new projects and
stuff like that I know you've got music
you're working like raw talent I'd like
to see you remix what's it called up I
love dick he taught me how to love
that's my favorite sandy cancer it's in
the movie
yeah I'd like to again I'd like to see
this movie cuz apparently were in it
sandy knows yeah she does so where are
we at Romeo was gonna pitch a good date
to sandy yes
something different Romeo where are you
gonna take sandy on your date Black
Caviar love it where are you alright
well let's see if we can get let's see
we yeah so I was I was like it's not
gonna happen
you know yeah I sometimes like but she's
a hottie [ __ ] me she does look great
today doesn't she she I she's a gorgeous
woman she's got balls she's got it like
a smelly [ __ ] what more could you want
melons please sandy your low blows are
old
oh okay definitely not old-school dumb
alright so let's go around the room
so you can't be nice to the [ __ ] if you
even want to you said our [ __ ] smelled
come on every woman's [ __ ] smells not
this one you're tired of smelling your
own that's why you're trying to talk for
everybody yeah yeah around my own [ __ ]
dish what yeah and you are
well you're not wearing any pantyhose
either right she's showing off the legs
she has no underwear on we for you do
you have cataract [ __ ] because I have
shorts
I don't need implants those procedures
would not be a negative I know might be
helpful definitely right surely I don't
need is more like I wish I could have
yeah yeah but at 30 years old to have
Botox and and implants I don't know
she looks great though she does look
good you could tell Botox you could tell
implants oh I want to get like something
you can't tell yeah it's weird cuz
hasn't seemed to hurt Mary's popularity
that's true I think I'm a little more
popular I know I told my mom I was
coming on Jim menorah and Jim Norton
insane robber show today and she goes I
know sandy came from the 80s she's still
around I thought she died oh wow how
comes the age know I thing is I don't
have time to get Botox and implants but
I would what are you doing I'm not on
the Jim and Sam channel to engage is
performing yeah everybody's succeeding
yeah like why are you being such a hater
still talking smack right we're all
doing well you got Romeo you know in the
deli Chris the bagel guy is still debate
guy Mary Jean is crushing it at the
beauty salon well-known in the 80s and
2019 come see me in Times Square's the
naked cowgirl in a curry
I'm making more money than ever the cops
are leaving me alone god bless them [ __ ]
alright let's go around the room
sandy see her in time I was gonna say if
we said just to put a bow on it sure to
see if we are good on a double date
sandy are you good on a double date yes
or no he just said no Romeo Galen yes
yes say yes Chris double date no and
marry double date I'll get back to
everyone
okay one more Jim and Sam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM Adam